good morning Hank it's Tuesday I can't
find my Norton Anthology of poetry I
don't mean the Norton Anthology of
poetry which can be purchased from any
bookstore I mean my Norton Anthology of
poetry or more specifically my friend
chips Norton Anthology of poetry that I
borrowed from him in 11th grade and then
eventually stole the third edition of
the Norton Anthology of poetry is a
deeply flawed book for one thing it
contains almost no poems from the last
40 years on account of having been
published 35 years ago but it is my
deeply flawed book or at the very least
chips and I can't find it one of the
central facts of my life is that no
matter how many times I reorganize my
home library in any given moment I will
not be able to find the book that I
desperately need like I can always find
the New York Public Library's guide to
organizing your home library
except when I'm embarking on a library
reorganization and I can always find my
ninth-grade copy of 100 poems by EE
Cummings except when it's March and I
want to quote that poem about spring
being like a perhaps hand which comes
carefully out of nowhere etc right now I
have no problem locating everything you
need to know about the goth scene I can
find plenty of copies of the Swedish
edition of Turtles all the way down and
it's amazing cover but I cannot find my
Norton Anthology of poetry it's not with
the poetry it's not with the hot wheels
ultimate tract it's not in the bookshelf
behind our bed and it's not in the
background of this video set although
while we're here two books have really
enjoyed reading recently this
extraordinarily engrossing biography of
Joseph Conrad which are not words I ever
thought I would say and dactyl Hill
Squad which doesn't come out until
September but I've been reading an
advanced copy with Henry it's about
orphans in the Civil War who ride
dinosaurs and it is amazing but that is
a tangent where is my Norton Anthology
of poetry I mean this is ridiculous I've
been looking for my Norton Anthology of
poetry for an entire day I haven't been
able to write a vlogbrothers script
because I've been looking for my Norton
Anthology of poetry which ergo has to
become the topic of today's vlogbrothers
video it's a 3.2 pound book nobody like
takes a three point two pound book on
vacation and leaves it there and yes I
know that I could just google the poem I
want to read but I don't want to google
it I want to read it in my Norton
Anthology of poetry which has to be
somewhere in this house I mean it's not
like I would have taken it out of that
wait a second
could it be at the office okay I'm gonna
drive to the office to look for my
Norton Anthology of poetry and if I
don't find it I am going to let it go
maybe I'm on my way to my office
on big money no whammies yes yes boa
tree the house was quiet and the world
was calm the reader became the book and
summer night was like the conscious
being of the book the house was quiet
and the world was calm the words were
spoken as if there was no book except
that the reader leaned above the page
wanted to lean wanted much most to be
the scholar to whom his book is true to
whom the summer night is like a
perfection of thought the house was
quiet because it had to be the quiet was
part of the meaning part of the mind the
access of perfection to the page and the
world was calm the truth in a calm world
in which there is no other meaning
itself is calm itself is summer and
night itself is the reader leaning late
and reading there oh it's every bit as
good as I remember and just what I
needed today Hank I will see you on
Friday